ou est-ce que je vous emmène aujourd'hui
je vous emmène dans la neige pour parler
quoi pour parler de ce nouveau samsung
galaxy s 21 est fait ouais on vient de
tester et alors je voulais tout de suite
pour tester on fait quoi et bien on fait
une toute la vidéo avec le samsung
galaxy s 21 il faut donc on en a deux
j'ai le mien et puis il ya celui là avec
mon coco qui filme ses seins en bocaux
ça un peu frais ça va un peu frais un
peu frais ça va alors la seule chose
qu'on s'est autorisé c'est d'utiliser un
micro externe donc là je de moumoute
j'ai un micro drogue pourquoi pas pour
avoir la meilleure qualité le son tel
que vous l'avez là vous pouvez
l'entendre la chantrerie fier mais tout
de suite sur mon smartphone sans aucun
micro le son est sympa mais est pas
complètement fou on voulait donc
l'optimiser met une petite bonne est
anti vent parce qu'il s'il ya du vent on
est en plein air on lit dans la nature
donc on va se faire toute la vidéo avec
le samsung galaxy s 21 et feu alors
qu'est ce qu'on va faire dans cette
vidéo et bien on va tous regardés on va
regarder ses smartphones et bien en
vidéo on va regarder s'il est bien en
photo en rade et tous les modes le
single take on a plein d'options
différentes pour toute la partie photo
vidéo on va également parler de la
performance vous avez un sens dragon 888
on a soit 6 soit une giga de ram avoir
gardé tout ce qui se passe pour ce
smartphone pour vous donner un retour
complet savoir s'il intéressant s'il est
de bonne facture si les bonnes qualités
et c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat que samsung parce
que samsonite yamoussoukro tu voudrais
pas à l'essayer ce smartphone comme tu
as envie je dis bien ok on va le faire
on va faire quoi on va aller faire du
chien de traîneau oui on va aller sur
quoi on va aller faire de la tyrolienne
oui et on va faire des cascades dans la
neige donc attention film à sensation il
se peut qu'on tombe il se peut qu'on
roule il se peut qu'on devienne un
bonhomme de neige parce qu'il fait froid
et que on n'a pas de gants mais pour
autant on est vachement bien on est ici
à super besse on n'est pas très loin de
clermont ferrand ville de villégiature
un très très bel endroit donc si ça vous
intéresse venez faire un tour ici en
hiver en tout cas on y va aujourd'hui
pour cette vidéo de test du samsung
galaxy s d'intérêt feu était bien
évidemment comme d'hab on me dit ce que
vous en pensez en bas on commentaires
ces partis allez on y va bien l'adage on
va dans leur plaire
[Musique]
donc là on est parti on faire un petit
tour de chiens de traîneaux comme sans
pouvoir tester en voie de stabilisation
alors plein de choses et puis on va
c'est un plaisir parce que regarder
juste énorme
[Musique]
j'étais en dépression qui veut dire un
truc ça lui derrière ça va les gars vous
suivez un ouais donc là on a fait un
petit tour des chiens de traîneau donc
ils sont très sympas c'est l'étoile sont
super millions donc on a testé plusieurs
choses on a testé quoi on a testé la
vidéo toujours onu hd à 60 images par
seconde on a testé également la
stabilisation donc la scène mode qui est
super stabilisés ou ont bien poussé un
peu plus qu'on peut le faire en ultra
grand-angle et en serrant enfin on a
filmé aussi en ralenti boutoir de venir
poser un peu plus le truc on a également
filmé au ralenti on a fait du super
ralenti et puis on a fait un truc qui
est vachement intéressant c'est le
double enregistrement où vous avez la
caméra de celle ci qui tourne également
la caméra derrière alors on peut
partager soit à voir les deux images de
la même taille soit voir une
incrustation vous avez votre caméra
derrière et vous en incrustation l'avant
ou alors votre caméra vous à l'avant et
l'incrustation de l'image d'arrière
c'est comme vous voulez donc sasaki
vachement intéressant c'était une très
grosse polyvalence qu'on peut venir
filmer ici avec ce nouveau samsung
galaxy s 21 et feu que ce soit pour du
ralenti que ce soit que ce soit pour du
slow motion que ce soit pour du partage
d'écran que ce soit pour venir filmer en
cas de cas urgent d bref on peut faire
vachement de choses et c'est vrai que si
vous voulez faire de la vidéo et si vous
voulez un smartphone qui vous permettent
beaucoup de flexibilité et c'est un truc
est vachement intéressant
tout ça a bien mérité une petite pause
qu'est-ce qu'on fait comme on en devient
débourser une petite truffade garder ça
c'est magnifique alors bien évidemment
comme d'hab on filme toujours tout au
galaxy s 21 et feu comme ça vous voyait
tout voyez même de la nourriture au même
film et de la nourriture donc si vous
êtes un bon vieux gourmands une bonne
vie gourmande va regarder ça c'est beau
c'est la mienne alors qu'est-ce qui vaut
ce samsung galaxy s 21 et feu en termes
de performance ils nous ont mis un stand
dragon 888 donc si vous voulez utiliser
pour du gaming vous n'aurai absolument
aucun problème en plus de ça vous avez
soit 6 soit 8 gigas de ram plus pareil
pour stockage vous avez soit 128 soit
256 go de stockage en ça ira très vite
en lecture en écriture alors qu'est ce
qui se passe au niveau de la batterie au
niveau de l'autonomie alors je sais pas
si vous l'avez vu parce que j'ai déjà
sorti une vidéo pour vous le présentez
vous avez une grosse batterie de 4500
milliampères heures versus 4000
milliampères heures avec le s 21 vous
avez ici de la recharge 25 watts alors
attention le bloc de charges n'est pas
inclus or c'est pas tout nouveau du côté
de chez samsung d'ailleurs samsung n'est
pas le seul à ne plus mettre ces blocs
de charge avec donc si vous voulez je
vous conseille réellement de venir
acheter votre chargeur votre chargeur
c'est votre blog de charger votre cap
directement sur le store de samsung
pourquoi et bien parce que ils se
reconnaissent ils communiquent avec vos
smartphones donc si vous prenez un bloc
de charges même très rapide d'une marque
concurrente ça ne marchera pas vous
aurez de la recharge l'entente saint
couat donc penser vraiment à acheter
soit un chargeur compatible soi et le
mieux c'est l'acheter directement sur le
store de samsung dont vous avez la
charge rapide 25 watts et au delà de ça
vous avez de la recharge sans fil 15
watts donc ça c'est bien et en termes
d'autonomie compter une journée et demie
alors cela dépendra bien évidemment si
vous y allez comme un gars comme un
sauvage comme un fou furieux vous aurez
une journée par un petit peu moins et
vous jouez comme un taré mais sur un
usage mixte on va dire une journée et
demie sans problème c'est une très bonne
moyenne et ça se tient parfaitement bien
en termes d'autonomie bravo samsung et
côté logiciel vous avez quoi vous
tournez sur when you 4.0 qui est basé
sur un android 12 alors je vous ai fait
une vidéo spéciale dans laquelle vous
montre les nouveautés principales de one
way 4.0 c'est vraiment super intéressant
ça se bat sur matériel ue de google bien
évidemment c'est de l'android 12 on
pouvait venir personnalisé vous avez
plein d'options niveau des widgets et
aussi quelques améliorations au niveau
de l'appareil photo bref ceux qui sont
super intéressant une fois de plus je
vous renvoie ma vidéo je vous remet un
lien sans quelque part par là soit dans
la description à les voir comme ça vous
saurez tout et vous allez voir un truc
est aussi vachement important au niveau
des smartphones c'est l'expérience
logiciel est ici l'expérience logiciels
chez samsung c'est une des meilleures du
marché ça serait dommage de louper ça
alors il ya un truc qui est vachement
bien sûr ce smartphone quand on prend en
main la première chose qu'on va tout de
suite c'est sa légèreté il est très
compact on peut vraiment envie de
refaire le tour comme ça avec la main ça
c'est vraiment génial coup qu'il est
extrêmement j'ai une super prise en main
et puis le dos surtout c'est du
plastique alors on pourrait se dire ok
on a un smartphone qui coûte quand même
un certain prix il est en plastique ça
fait râler si vous vous souvenez le s 21
l'année dernière était déjà avec un dos
en plastique mais il avait tout une
petite partie en métal notamment au
niveau de la partie photo et qui
descendait sur le côté ici ils ont tous
mis en plastique même la partie au
niveau de l'appareil photo alors de vous
à moi ça me dérange pas je me suis
habitué à ça serait quand j'ai vu
arriver des smartphones haut de gamme
avec du plastique non mais c'est pas
possible et puis au final samassa
fonctionne parce que quand on pousse la
réflexion on se dit que nos smartphones
on fait quoi on met des coques de
protection donc c'est pas un problème
n'est quand même le protéger pour éviter
les problèmes mais et rassurez-vous vous
avez à l'avant un corning gorilla glass
victimes il va venir le protégé évité
s'il tombe de venir sans dommage et
alors si vous le tombé sur un coin de
cailloux c'est pas magique non plus mais
pour autant d'une résistance et quand
même maximiser et en plus de ça c'est un
smartphone qui est certifié résistant à
l'eau et à la poussière avec une
certification ip68 s'il vous plaît
prendre le smartphone pourrait venir le
poser dans la neige dans la pluie alors
l'idée effectivement c'est pas de le
poser dans la neige ou de la pluie mais
si vous le posez il y aura absolument
aucun problème vous récupérer après a
bien évidemment vous le sécheur parce
qu'on n'aime pas avant le smartphone
mouillé c'est un peu pénible mais ça ne
posera pas de problème ça ira bien donc
on est un smartphone qui est léger qui
se prend bien en main qui est compacte
qui a de belles finitions qu'un corning
gorilla glass bectu ce qui pèse 68 kg à
toutes les options autant vous dire
qu'ici on a le combo gagnant et qui
disent qu'un dragon 888 10,5 j'ai donc
c'est un smartphone qui a de la 5g et
qui vous accompagnera dans les années à
venir sans aucun problème vous avez bien
évidemment du nfc pour le paiement
dématérialisé donc c'est plutôt pratique
bref il a tout ce qu'on attend d'un
smartphone actuel aujourd'hui en 2022 un
autre élément essentiel c'est l'écran
ils ont vraiment pas lésiné on un
superbe écran alors on connaissait déjà
la qualité des écrans de samsung vous
avez ici la même dalle que vous aviez
dans l'es21 cdu dynamique amoled 2 x
sauf qu'ici vous avez un écran de 6 4
pouces contre 6,2 pouces sur le s 21 on
se situe en fait entre le s-21 ultras
qui était sur du 6 juin le 7 pouces
énorme et le s 21 à 6,4 poussé hyper
confort pour venir jouer à des jeux
après y'a un truc intéressant c'est que
vous avez ici un taux de
rafraîchissement de 100 verte ce n'est
pas un taux de rafraîchissement
adaptatif c'est soit 120 hertz soit 60
hertz c'est soit l'un soit l'autre c'est
pas les deux en même temps c'est pas
d'appétit ce qui fait que si vous voulez
jouer à des jeux vous voulez beaucoup de
fluidité pourquoi pas scrollé sur
instagram y avoir d'affinité venait dans
vos paramètres changé est passé on
s'emmerde si vous voulez par contre
économiser de la batterie switcher en 60
hertz mais ça sera soit l'un soit
l'autre il ce n'est pas sur une
résolution wqvga plus on est sur du full
hd ça ira parfaitement bien et en plus
de ça lorsque la nuit arrive lorsque la
pénombre et là que vous voulez venir
regarder des films des séries aux joues
est con c'est pas trop le soir mais on
le fait tous moi aussi moi le premier
d'ailleurs et bien vous avez ici un
écran qui est certifié lutter contre la
lumière bleue ça vous évitera de la
fatigue oculaire et ça c'est cool côté
expérience musicale pour le multimédia
on a des haut parleurs stéréo dolby
atmos ça va bien un peu déséquilibré
mais ça ira très bien ce que je vous
conseille quand même c'est de venir
utiliser ça ça ce sont les galaxies buzz
ii de samsung et les galaxy 2 2 ils sont
très cools pourquoi et bien déjà parce
qu'ils ont une toute petite forme et ils
sont sympa en plus de ça lorsque vous
les ouvrez et bien vous avez une couleur
qui va être complètement identique à
celle de votre smartphone il existe en
graphite il existe en la vendant nos
lives en bref il existe en différentes
couleurs ils deviennent très bien
positionné dans vos oreilles vous avez
de la réduction brute à petit bassin cet
homme très très joli produit et ce qui
est super intéressant c'est que jusqu'au
8 février ils sont offerts et justement
maintenant on va parler du prix du
samsung galaxy s 21 et feu ce smartphone
le samsung galaxy s 21 et feu il coûte
soit 759 euros dans la config si giga de
ram 128 giga de stockage soit 829 euros
dans la config 8 gigas de ram 256 go de
stockage et c'est un petit peu compliqué
parce que je trouve aujourd'hui un peu
cher alors rassurez vous si vous
l'achetez tout de suite jusqu'au 8
février avec petit alexis boeuf de veau
faire c'est super canon le tarif est
super intéressant et vous avez un
ensemble qui marchera très bien la
regarder ya un truc est vachement
impressionnant ce smartphone il est
super bien en pleine lumière là vous
avez un plein soleil vous me direz on
n'est pas en été mais quand même on est
en plein soleil et on voit drôlement
bien au niveau de la conf il faut tout
revoir sensiblement la même chose qu'on
avait sur le s 21 vous allez avoir le
même grand angle même ultra grand-angle
12 mégapixels tous les deux sur le grand
temps que vous avez un duel pixels
c'était l'objectif qui va changer au
lieu d'avoir un 64 mégapixels vous avez
un 8 mégapixels avec un zoom optique x 3
et on va jusqu'à un zoom x 30 ans
numérique et à l'avant au lieu d'avoir
une caméra de celle fille de 10
mégapixels sur le s 21 et si vous avez
un 30 2 mégapixels pour bosser le fit
don c'est plutôt sympa on est le soir au
studio je filme toujours avec le s 21 et
feu son petit frère est ici on va
regarder les photos parce que ça
racontait si la qualité est bonne alors
regardez je vous montre déjà le touch
vous vraiment excellent alors il ya
beaucoup de lumière les conditions sont
vraiment idéales mais regardez là c'est
juste magnifique où les dans des
conditions de montagne avec beaucoup
lumière c'est super agréable mais
regardez ce qu'on arrive à faire on le
devine la juste devant le résultat est
vraiment complètement dingue et ça
marche bien on voit sur toutes les
photos c'est toujours un peu la même
chose gardez là où passent sur l'ultra
grand angle vous voyez que lorsqu'on
vient ce goût mais qu'on se rapprochent
beaucoup trop ça fonctionne pas mais
c'est normal regardez là c'est juste
magnifique le ciel bleu la montagne la
route j'ai vraiment tout cas superbe et
même sur des photos qui sont prises à
contre jour il ya une très très bonne
gestion et je trouve que c'est pas mal
fait c'est pas sûr jouer trouve que l'ia
va pas faire trop de boulot la
différence de certains smartphones où il
ya côté qui est pas naturel et si c'est
extrêmement bien naturel très bien
maîtrisé j'adore le boulot est fait ici
regardez surtout qu'est aussi bluffant
on est vraiment sur un contre jour on a
le soleil on a les armes je trouve ça
marche vraiment bien on vient se
rapprocher un peu on va tous les détails
sur le tronc avec le lichen et la mousse
ça marche super bien et même sur les
arts pour me retrouver au fond une fois
de plus c'est extrêmement bluffant on
est parti faire du chien de traîneau
regardez c'est pareil les chiens ils ont
pris la pause ça marche vraiment bien
rendus sur les chiens qui extrêmement
nettes du détail au niveau des poils
c'est vraiment vraiment top et même en
balade ça marche bien alors on voit
qu'ici effectivement c'est un peu plus
cramer pourquoi parce que l'expo est
fait pour redonner un peu plus ombragé
mais dans l'ensemble c'est extrêmement
cohérente le mode portrait que je trouve
aussi efficace ici à savoir vous n'avez
pas de laser vous n'avez pas de leader
vous n'avez rien du tout il n'y a pas de
capteur dédié d'ailleurs au mode
portrait mais pour autant le résultat
est vraiment l'un très beau détourage et
ça fonctionne bien ultra grand-angle va
être moins net on va voir à côté
déformant au niveau des angles mais dans
l'ensemble ça fait le boulot alors vous
avez les limites on est sur un tel
objectif c'est un 8 mégapixels on peut
faire un zoom x 3 optique n'aura pas
aller au delà car des voix y on est sur
un x 30 c'est vraiment pas terrible on
peut rien en faire si vous voulez le
faire surtout marek votre smartphone
vous pouvez mais au-delà de ça non
regardez le résultat sur la glace c'est
l'appareil vachement bien super beau
alors là vous avez un double combo qui
intéressant le mode portrait qu une fois
de plus marche bien des tours bien est
super intéressant leur a prévenu dans ma
vidéo / ou annuels 4.0 vous verrez qu'on
préfère pas mal de petites choses au
niveau du mode portrait après en post
prod directement depuis votre smartphone
et puis en plus ça voyez les teintes
chair je trouve super bien fait très
réaliste c'est une fois de plus un super
bon boulot ici et très bien maîtrisée de
la part de samsung après vous avez le
mode single take vous savez vous lancer
un enregistrement pendant 15 secondes et
vous sortent plusieurs fichiers des
fichiers vidéo avance et recule et on va
voir un accéléré ralenti bref c'est
assez marrant et ça nous sort des photos
regardez là en plein mouvement avec le
mode single take ça vous sort des photos
qui sont vraiment sympas qui marche bien
du noir et blanc à certaines qui sont
colorisées et je trouve ça extrêmement
efficace vous fait aussi un petit
panorama bref ça m'a vachement bien et
comme je voulais dit dans ma vidéo
d'astuces ou dire plus rajouté cinq
secondes en plus et qu'un second de
monter jusqu'à 20 secondes et pourquoi
pas regarder ça les détails impeccable
gestion d'autres lumières qui est
vraiment beau dans une très bonne place
x et ça marche super super super super
la gestion des photos de nuit aussi est
assez bonne alors on va pas aller sur
les ultra grand angle on va pas venir
vous m'aimez vous restez sur votre
grand-angle principal ça marche très
très bien vous voyez sur l'ultra
grand-angle ces terres ne sait pas où on
va on vient à oublier mais regardez on
arrive à sortir des détails très bonne
gestion des lumières et dans l'ensemble
ça fera vraiment bien bull en selle si
on arrive à son terme des trucs pas trop
mal au niveau de l'arrière plan c un peu
brute et c'est pas forcément les
meilleures photos qu'on va avoir même si
on est un capteur et plus de pixels que
le s 21 bon on arrive à faire des choses
mais voilà c'est pas mal mais pas
complètement ce qu'il faut retenir ici
c'est d'excellentes photos avec votre
capteur principal lorsque vous avez
beaucoup lumière même un peu moins de
lumière ça marche très très bien on fait
aussi de très belles choses avec ultra
grand-angle le thé l'objectif est pas
mal en faut trois monts va pas au delà
la caméra de celle qui sortira des
choses sont pas sans être complètement
dingos on peut des photos nues qui sont
très bonnes sans grand angle et après
vous avez aussi un très bon rendu en
terme de vidéo soit sur des vidéos un
peu accéléré un hyper l'aps comme on
peut faire directement ici avec son
smartphone que vous ayez aussi un effet
ralenti ou alors vous soyez vraiment sur
un super slow motion ou ça vous génère
une vidéo vous voyez par exemple les
chiens qui courent ici dans vous le vrai
rêve antilles et ça repart et c'est
extrêmement bluffant qu'au terme de
photos et de vidéos pour moi c'est un
très bon photophone il a rien à envier
aux plus grands bilan final de ce
samsung galaxy s 21 et feu et bien un
excellent smartphone très bon très bien
équilibrée excellent écran beaucoup de
performances une batterie qui tient la
roue très bon en photos aussi bon en
vidéo d'ailleurs vous l'avez eu parce
que toute la vidéo a été filmée avec ce
samsung galaxy s 21 et fuck je compte
sur vous maintenant pour mieux ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire
comment vous le trouvez comment vous
allez trouver cette vidéo est ce que ça
vous a intéressé ce format où nous
emmène sur le terrain smartphone à la
main à les tester des choses allaient
découvrir des choses comment vous
trouvez ce samsung galaxy s 21 et
feuilles puis n'oubliez pas jusqu'au 8
février vous avez l'offre avec les
galaxy buzz de offert et ça c'est
vachement intéressant il m'a tout ce que
vous en pensez en bas en commentaire non
se retrouve très vite pour continuer à
parler tech et ça et ça c'est une
excellente nouvelle je vous embrasse à
bientôt ciao
[Musique]